citizens of the reject nation we are
back to watch gravity falls today
uh i know that we missed last week uh
that's just because there was so much
happening like d23 and all these other
things that we just didn't get around to
it however thank you for being patient
i'm excited to continue this john what
episode are we on we are on season two
episode i believe 16
way to go dude just off the dominant
well guys you know what to do as i'm
pulling this up you can leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated also you
know subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our next reaction for gravity falls is
up here on the channel full length
scratch and watch long as we sync up
with your own copy of gravity falls
available for super sexy rejects at our
patreon page lastly the team at prepper
thank you for helping us edit down these
highlights and swing action
every year my tourist trap competitors
prank the mystery shack last year those
hooligans duct taped zeus to the ceiling
this year we're visiting every tourist
trap along the redwood highway and i'm
gonna prank back every single one wow
sweet
what do you say dude you're coming i
already went to the trouble of packing
all your stuff even the stuff you kept
in that secret box under the bed
oh
no i still have that
uh nothing just
wendy stuff from old times
i thought you were finally past all this
ah i know i know
i know she's not interested and i know
it's over but how do you just turn off
the way you feel about someone you punch
yourself
repression road trip's the perfect place
to meet new people
[Music]
you could be that guy
that guy in the photo you could be that
guy
[Music]
man our fees are amazing i can't believe
we're sitting at a table in a moving
vehicle oh i want to do it woman lit my
car on fire on two non-consecutive
occasions so
i'm going in girls
[Laughter]
i'm a tourist
you're funny and cute i mean not cute i
mean you're not not cute
let me start over my name is dopper
that romper though thinking about miss
cold shoulder over there huh ah i'm so
embarrassed look earlier this summer i
ruined my chances with wendy
yeah
chances
listen to me kid when it comes to girls
always be confident and be funny but not
too funny it'd be kind of annoying but
in a lovable way
the three c's of the standpine's dating
technique at the next tourist trap try
out my advice on the first girl you see
cool thanks it could work hey i'm full
of good ideas speaking of which everyone
now
[Laughter]
where you go darling
[Music]
downtown
what push of blood to the head
crazy place right i'm emma sue you know
if you pretend we're right side up it
looks like everyone's hair is standing
on end huh yeah weird right pretend
you're screaming okay you gotta take a
picture of me though
oh
emma come on we have to get to canada
before your mother gives birth it's a
long story maybe you could tell me
sometime here's my email address write
me and i'll tell you all about it oh
what a keel girl your email and it
wasn't out of pity
yes
[Music]
i'm okay how does this work i know
brenda candy looking great looking great
is that a new pair of glasses very shiny
[Music]
maybe it's the blood pooling in my head
but dipper seems different
[Music]
different
[Music]
what a lovely normal home
stan
[Laughter]
i can't believe it worked what do i do
now do i email her no no no the more
girls you talk to the better you get at
it and that's just the tip of the advice
berg nicely done
[Music]
everyone on board probably dude i want
that sweater and earrings combo that
she's got you're not gonna see any of
these gals again
okay it's time for truth i dare you or
salt i choose don't
ah you always jews don't
tell us
okay it begins with a d
and ends with an eeper
ready granda three two one
all my life dreams are coming true right
now my brother my best friend i can't
breathe i'm so excited i can't breathe
but how do i approach him don't even
worry about that can can mabel's got a
plan
[Music]
[Applause]
neville
today the mountain falls
question the back seat makes me carsick
can i sit up front today also a question
i'm the size of two people can i have a
whole seat to myself
change up
but wait that means it'll be just me and
candy too sixth grade
so deeper i was wondering would you
maybe want to walk around the mystery
mountain with me today
sure
[Laughter]
golly
you and me candy and deeper
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
paul bunyan and his blue ox babe five
bucks for whoever can tip the big blue
ox go go go
i will see you in there
way to flirt man i just need to be
honest with her and tell her i i'm not
ready for all this that's your dumb
obsession with wendy getting in the way
of your future if you want to move on
you got to say yes to whatever comes
your way speaking of which
go for it
but i don't want to lead her on ah watch
and learn
i've lost my number can i borrow yours
oh
you are a riot what brings you here we
don't normally get men this handsome
you know i'm going on a break you want
to take the sky tram up to widow's peak
take my advice or don't but clearly i
know what i'm doing
get that trampians
i wonder what they'll name the baby if i
had a baby i would name it grenda too
you would make such a good mother
this place is so enchanting sort of
confused by the phrase new mummies daily
is my head falling on your shoulder
[Music]
uh
yep this is what i want this is all part
of the plan and stuff oh different hey
oh golly miss molly dipper who is this
nobody i mean uh somebody but dipper
i didn't recognize you right side up no
this is john's nightmare
that's right guys which one of us do you
like i
i like all of you i mean i don't like
any of you i mean
i was trying to learn how to talk to
girls
unbelievable so gross confidence will
destroy you guys that's right it's not
worth it don't worry toots that spider
people stuff is just an urban legend i
can't believe people fall for it you're
so brave what can i say i'm a real catch
yes
uh i think your contacts fell out
uh have you seen an old guy around here
uh big ears orange nose
so remember how we were talking about my
technique well sometimes it leads to
unexpected consequences the good news is
i've solved the mystery of where
oregon's mummies come from the bad news
is i'm about to become one
did you make the call
oh
i don't know one minute we're having the
perfect date and the next minute she's
growing extra legs and encasing me in
webbing you couldn't tell she was a
spider i was blinded by flattery also
this acid she spit in my face
all right i'm gonna find you stay put
you got it
you're so funny great story i love a man
with shoulder hair you you didn't mean
it about my shoulder hair
you
devil woman
sorry tuts this time you're getting used
for your body which to my weird species
is food allow me to slip into something
more horrifying
[Music]
wow
girls
there you are betrayer oh you what do
you want i need your help with what some
sick jealousy trap yes sing it candy
[Laughter]
but stan's in trouble you can totally
kill me later but right now he needs us
i don't know if you're really up there
or not but if you are please save me
paul bunyan
times whoa did that really work
go grinder the sky trim everybody on
perfect world's slowest treetop tram
ride enjoy the sights at 0.1 miles per
hour ah can't this thing go any faster
no it can't
it's creepy
[Music]
enjoying the view take a picture
[Applause]
[Music]
below us is oregon's largest poor bunion
statue an old reliable goes off in five
four candy wait please don't pull that
lever kid are you crazy
this is a terrible idea
[Music]
[Laughter]
kid that was ingenious how'd you know
that would work useless travel pamphlets
stanley
i'm sorry i don't know what came over me
you let me out shoot her
kill it with fire leslie do i look like
an amnesiac
[Laughter]
you're so funny
have you ever considered becoming a
comedian
you know i actually have no
you win this round stan but mark my
words as long as there's men like you
out there with their dumb one-liners and
pick-up moves i'll never run out of prey
confidence can buy you a lot but at the
end of the day pickup artists tend to
get our heads bitten off
when it comes to women i'm a failure
hey we're both failures
that's the lesson i actually haven't
thought about wendy all day plus you did
teach me to be more confident i guess i
just need to learn to use that power for
good
hey i found a pamphlet i don't think
you've read yet
[Music]
after seeing you flee the spider like a
baby i kind of lost interest yep yep i
deserve that
i never have to face any consequence
sweet lord
oh come on
that's what you get that's what you get
i don't understand i completely don't
deserve this
nah i'm sure seuss will take care of it
where is seuss anyway
okay seuss remember what your grandma
taught you when you get lost stay
exactly where you are and don't move
seems awful
okay
drama was like seeing your nightmare
come to life
uh it was a great learning lesson for me
and i'm uh gonna you know try and use my
confidence powers for good now that i've
uh learned the error of my way this is a
real like it was like watching a
christmas carol except i didn't have to
live it out i didn't have to you know
take the trip i got to watch dipper do
it and now i can learn secondhand from
his experiences and become a better
person
i hope so yeah too many women too many
chicks there's a curse i've
never had to deal with
well you don't want it
i'd like it for
you know like a moment
for like uh for like a week i just want
to say no yeah i want to reject ooh
what power
yeah yeah it's about time men have the
power yes
to reject women
to rebuke their advances and make them
feel embarrassed for trying
this is a fun episode i liked it
it was fun i think the girls were funny
i think uh
girls are funny dipper's very relatable
situation for many a guy out there
always having to learn to be it's the
combination of funny and confident the
ability to close and not try too hard
along the way ah that's that was a good
one god damn that was good that was a
good lesson for him to have learned
and uh definitely turn way too many
women on
i know poor son of a bee i bet this
episode was was banned at the time
for just being too titillating too
sexual too sexy for my tv screen
and it also had this interesting wrap
around
about
um you know like
people wrong stan he felt and then he
sought revenge and then
the spider lady seeks
declares vengeance
at the very end so there's there's a
whole thing here about revenge and
revenge but gets revenge yeah is that
crazy so much deeper than just some
silly episode about being on the road
and trying to pick up girls and
encountering a hot spider woman
one two it makes you wonder because as
much as you want to be like yeah you
know
revenge just be gets more revenge i'm
like
of all the things it actually does seem
like stan has
something of a ground to stand on if it
is in fact that every other mystery you
know curio location has been pranking
him for years i feel like
they can each take one
although he did like full-on destroy
their attractions so i guess he took it
too far and that's the lesson i feel
like he's full of s-h-i-t oh
because you know like even at the very
end he's like i completely did not
deserve this so i'm sure something
happened already probably
makes sense lies to himself
yeah he's probably not telling us the
full truth he's lying by omission but if
dipper had that type of
comedy and confidence around wendy could
make a difference
yeah now that he's got that power he
should come back and give it a try and
not learn and then unlearn every lesson
except the lesson of confidence i've
seen a lot of people escape that friend
zone
it's wait there's a way to get out of it
and uh
i feel like dipper's got a future there
well who else could wendy end up with
that would be better than dipper nobody
i actually didn't like that was i wasn't
opposed to the idea of candy and dipper
no not at all i thought it was kind of a
neat twist i wouldn't have expected
yeah
i mean
i've i've like
you know nerdy asian girls before
so i relate yeah
true that you got like at least one
at least one nerdy asian girl sure your
whole life you gotta have at least one
nerdy asian girl you like yeah this is
yeah it's a requirement
one nerdy asian girl um one like valley
girl white chick
uh a sassy black girl to get your
stereotypes in i do feel like it's been
a lot of filler though lately as fun as
this episode was and i would like it to
uh
get back
to where we belong
when you had such good momentum there
yeah
and i feel like it's mainly been like
we're laughing at stuff this is fun
um but
i am kind of craving a little bit more
now and i'm hoping that now that we're
in the home stretch of the last few
episodes that we can get back there you
want more stanford you want more of that
diaries and and bill cipher i know i
feel you yeah well this is just the
adventure of the week yeah true though
you guys see more of the world expanding
beyond just gravity falls and seeing
that no this this far expands gravity
falls yeah it's the whole state of
oregon yeah you can do a whole lot more
crazy
crazy hijinks out there which
which i appreciate and you know dipper
and stan get in and have a real uncle
nephew bonding
male thing i think it's cool
it's a necessary part of his puberty
development that's right
however we got a bigger story at play
here and i i'm starting to itch for
getting back there as enjoyable as
everyone was in this episode i am i'm
getting an itch
yeah yeah i feel you i mean i i thought
this episode like the i liked how uh
like icky and and creepy it got um but
yeah like i wonder if the uh mystery
mountain or whatever it's called could
could factor back in in any way because
the rest of the attractions are just you
know
oddities that could easily be
orchestrated by humans whereas that is
like oh there's there's some real
supernatural stuff going on here and
some real like creature horror happening
so maybe
i don't know it's got something to do
with the journals is this really just an
isolated incident i don't know but
i did like uh just the aesthetics of all
the different attractions that they went
to i thought those were all very fun and
charming yeah lots of great little sight
gags or blink and you'll miss it little
jokes and things
and yeah like the spider lady i thought
was actually icky was actually sort of
like skin crawling
and what are you gonna do yeah what you
gonna do we'll get back to it soon
enough i'm sure this show will end
powerfully
all right guys we'll leave your thoughts
down below subscribe click that bell
leave a like still had a really fun time
watching it in the moment
and uh hey let's send us with a patreon
maria hammond who by the way gave me a
very generous birthday gift and thank
you maria for just being the sweetheart
that you are we have looked up your name
on urban dictionary
i'm sorry if this sounds insulting
maria is a person who can always make
you smile in any way
wow urban dictionary you're being rude
about our girl maria calm down ud she is
a funny sweet girl who always knows how
to put you in a good mood they aren't
you're not
holding back right now jesus
she's beautiful and can make friends
with anyone wow i am offended on your
behalf how could you insinuate such a
thing however she is sensitive and
sometimes needs space to gather her
thoughts wow there is no need for this
language on the internet no need
but she is an amazing friend and you
should hold on to them forever i'm going
to write urban dictionary a letter and
have this revolt
i'm so sorry on behalf of us all i'm
sorry on behalf of stephen urban i am
sorry too and my dictionary
we will fix this i promise you this is
not a reflection of urban dictionaries
morals and values of what the company
actually would be yeah please
please don't blame them sorry
but no seriously this is all very
accurate maria
and you are an incredible woman and i
saw some of your uh interview with the
the talking talking movie trivia that
was that was cool man that was cool i'm
glad to see you doing some on camera
work you're natural
and thank you for being you dear
we'll talk soon like we always do
[Music]
you